hey what's going on folks I just want to
start off by saying thank God when I
woke up this morning my channel was
still restored and all my videos were
stolen there for those of you that
didn't see the video that I posted last
night
real quick briefly discussing it I'll
just go over it real quick with you guys
just so some of you know because only a
few hundred of you actually saw that
video and I just checked my comments and
someone asked me about it they said they
saw that my channel disappeared for a
day basically what happened was and I'm
going to share with you those notices
that I good I took a few screenshots of
the notices that YouTube and Google sent
me and I want to share those with you
guys so you can see exactly what I saw
but basically two days ago I got an
alert on my phone from Google saying
there were a suspicious activity on my
account and it asked me to enter my
phone number that way it could send me a
six digit code to verify my account so I
put my phone number in they sent me the
six digit code I put the code in and
then it sent me to this page and I'll
post a photo right here so you guys can
see what I read when I got on that page
and I'll give you a few seconds to read
it
and as you can see it basically says my
channels disabled so I was thinking what
the hell like why was there suspicious
activity on my account
why is my channel disabled and I don't
think you can actually see it and this
noticed but at the bottom it basically
gave me a little space for me to type a
message and give a reason for why I
think my channel was taken down so I
basically just typed I have no idea why
my channel was taken down will you guys
please tell me what happened and it also
said if the problem wasn't resolved
immediately my channel was going to be
terminated for good but it said that it
would send me an email giving me a
detailed reason for why this is
happening so I started to panic and I
immediately went to youtube to try to
sign in to this channel that I'm talking
to you guys on right now and when I put
in my password this is what I saw and
you can see it said the channel was
already terminated so I was like what
the hell is going on they didn't even
give me a chance to fight my case they
just terminated my channel for really no
reason at least they didn't give me a
reason I assumed I followed all the same
rules that all the other YouTube Game of
Thrones channels were following I don't
think I use any more content than some
of the other ones do so I was pretty
damn confused and I posted something on
Twitter
I know only a couple of you follow my
Twitter account I wish more of you would
follow my Twitter account if you do have
a twitter please go to that account it
should be linked on this YouTube channel
that way if my channel does go down
again you guys will be able to contact
me so that way when if I have to start a
new one eventually you guys will know
where to find me if you even care to do
so but as of right now I'm able to sign
into my channel and I went to my
guidelines and I'll show you this photo
- I still have zero copyright strikes
and zero guideline community strikes so
I really don't know what happened I
still haven't received an email from
Google or YouTube telling me what
happened so I'm still pretty confused
and I just wanted to go over this
again and show you guys these photos
because there was a few people that
actually questioned whether I was
telling the truth or not
and I definitely wouldn't make this up
so I want you guys to see this stuff and
you can actually see in this other photo
how much my views actually went down for
the past couple weeks I was averaging
about 20,000 views every 48 hours and
you can see in this photo that in the
past 48 hours I only had 4000 views and
you can actually see a big gap in his
views to where I didn't get any at all
so you can see that my channel was down
for a complete 24 hours so I have no
idea what the hell happened if you guys
tried to look for a new video from me
yesterday or the day before and you
didn't see one or it didn't let you
access this channel I know someone just
left a comment saying it said my channel
was terminated this is why and I still
don't know why but thanks for sticking
around I lost some subscribers about 30
or 40 but that's alright someone left
the comment last night saying hey at
least your loyal ones stuck around this
way we weeded out some of the bad apples
I completely agree thank you for saying
that thanks for all the nice comments
you guys left I really appreciate that
I'm glad you guys are still here I'm
glad all of you didn't try to find my
next video and saw that my channel was
terminated some of you might not even
know this happen
luckily you didn't see it and just
jumped ship so I'm glad you guys are
still here so let's move forward and
start talking some Game of Thrones again
and in today's video it's going to be my
continuation of the plot league
breakdown and we are now at episode 7
which is the season 7 finale so let's
read through this episode then start
breaking this stuff down alright episode
7 songs as sentences Littlefinger to
death which arya carries out some time
earlier in the season Littlefinger
attempted to pit Arya and Sansa against
each other by using an old letter sunzha
wrote under duress by the Lannisters to
Robb Stark bran helps sons and see if
their little fingers ploy Cersei wakes
up in a bed soaked with blood presumably
from a miscarriage at some point earlier
in the season there is a plot that
so she finds out she is pregnant with
Jamie's child Sam and bran figure out
John's parentage that he is the son of
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen and
that his real name is Aegon and he was
legitimized at birth he is not a bastard
John and Danny have sex on a boat headed
north and at the end of the episode the
wall Falls the night's king attacks it
with the zombie dragon Viserion
and he is able to knock it down okay so
let's go back to the beginning and start
break breaking down each section of this
episode okay at the beginning it says
Sansa sentences Littlefinger to death
Arya then carries it out some time
earlier in the season Littlefinger
attempted to pit re and sones against
each other by using the old letter Sansa
wrote under duress by the Lannisters to
Robb Stark and brain hopes Songz's see
through little fingers ploy so just to
remind a few you about that letter this
was when the Lannisters actually had Ned
Stark locked up and this was when Robb
Stark was beginning to rebel because he
knew that his father was right and that
Joffrey wasn't the next heir to the
throne
so Cersei basically forced Sansa to
write her brother robb and tell him to
stand down and swear fealty to Joffrey
Cersei said this would help save her
father from being executed so sands of
course wrote the letter she really
didn't have much of a choice at this
point I know the Lannisters needed one
of the stark girls to basically take
control of the north but I think if
Sansa refused to write this letter
Cersei or Joffrey probably would have
had her killed as evil as those two are
I could have seen them taking her out so
more than likely Littlefinger will do
what he does best and that sneak behind
Songz's back and probably start to
whisper nor his ear making her question
songs his loyalty to the stark family
which is kind of ridiculous
Sansa did just help save John's life at
the Battle of the bastards so she
obviously loves her family but there
could be a chance that Littlefinger
could even know that Sansa wasn't too
worried about save and Rickon but it's
obvious sunzha knew what type of person
Ramsay was he was never going to let
ricky'll and get out alive but you know
how Littlefinger is he can
the perception anyway he wants that's
what he's the best at but you think when
aria was the cup bearer for Tywin
Lannister she saw a little finger
talking to Tywin so she knew that
Littlefinger was secretly working for in
supporting the Lannisters so I'd be
surprised if she would even consider
anything Littlefinger would say I would
think as soon as arya saw him again she
would have to question his true
intentions but that's how Littlefinger
is so great whenever he is up against
the ropes are backed into a corner he
can always talk his way out of it he is
literally a silver tongue devil and as
much as I love the Starks I want to see
him dead for what he has done to them I
will miss his character on the show I
think he had such an interesting dynamic
to the show but in the end all men must
die and come Season eight the show won't
have much use for its political
characters anymore I think the world is
going to be at war with the White
Walkers and they do not seem to want to
negotiate so if you're not a character
on the battlefield I could easily see
the show when I start killing off these
characters Littlefinger is probably a
first or at the very least a second-tier
character so I'm sure he makes a
significant amount of money per episode
money that the show will need for CGI in
season eight I expect the battles in
season eight to be like nothing we've
ever seen before in television history
so if you're a character just sitting on
the sidelines I won't be surprised to
see them go because we know the battles
in season eight are going to be
literally epic all the forces are going
to be together there's probably going to
be thousands hundreds of thousands or
millions of whites all the White Walkers
the dragons are going to be fighting the
White Walkers that's going to cost a lot
of money so I think if you're a
character that's on the sidelines or
behind the scenes they're probably not
going to want to pay you that money to
just kind of sit around but that's just
my opinion
I really don't know but I must say I
would prefer to see Sansa be the one to
execute Littlefinger her father always
said the man that passes the sentence
should swing the sword and I'd love to
see her honor her father's words in+
considering all the [ __ ] Littlefinger
has done to Songza it would be very
fitting and satisfied
like to see her be the one to take him
out but we know Aria is the killer
between the two and she's going to be
chopping at the bit to kill someone that
is doing her or her family wrong so
it'll be just as cool to see her do it
and we know Tyrion said Sansa is not a
killer but he said not yet so I actually
do think we are going to see her
personally kill someone at some point in
the show at least I hope so
she's been dragged through the mud and
treated like [ __ ] for a very long time
so I think she's due to take somebody
out but anyway let's move on next it
says Cersei wakes up in a bed soaked
with blood presumably from a miscarriage
at some point earlier in the season
there was a blood thread where Cersei
finds out she is pregnant with Jaime's
child now I really don't know what to
say about this
I understand Cersei wanting an heir to
the throne but I don't know what purpose
it shows with them showing her having a
miscarriage I don't know what the point
of that is so if any of you know what
point this serves to the current story
on the show please let me know because I
really don't get it so I'm just going to
move right past his part and next it's a
Sam and brand somehow figure out John's
parentage and that he is the son of
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen his
real name is Aegon and was legitimized
at birth now I'm very confused by this
I'm not sure why it would say bran
somehow figured out John's parentage too
as if he is just now learning this I
think bran should already know this we
know in the Tower of joy scene Sam sorry
bran clearly said that's my aunt Lyanna
so he has to know that was the baby that
his dad brought home from the war
lianna's baby who was Jon Snow so bran
should already know the story that songs
a new - if you remember when songs and
Littlefinger was down in the crypts
Sansa said that Rhaegar abducted Lyanna
so if I was him or sorry I don't know
why I keep saying Sam if I was bran
wouldn't you put two and two together
and Blake okay that's my aunt Lyanna
right there having a baby boy and
there's my father taking that baby
the father or so the son that my father
brought home from the war that is John
Snow was obviously layana's baby and my
dad didn't cheat on my mom so who was
Leona with at the Tower of joy
what is the story I've heard my whole
life about Leona
she was taken and abducted by Rhaegar
Targaryen
so bran should assume that has to be
Rhaegar son as well so I'm not sure why
it says brain is just not figuring this
out as well but it is interesting to see
that Sam may have found out do you think
that means he read it somewhere like
maybe he found a hidden marriage
certificate or birth certificate
somewhere or some kind of record
personally I believe John is legitimate
I don't know about his name being Aegon
I really don't I don't think that's his
name I really don't have much evidence
for me to provide you guys with but I
just believe that he's legitimate it's
something I felt for a very long time
and I know you guys have a lot of good
reasons for why John is still a bastard
there are very good points but I still
just believe this deep down it's
something that I already made a video
about which most of you commented on and
a lot of you disagreed with but that's
all right I think at some point in the
future we are definitely going to find
this out whether this part of the leak
is true or not I don't know
but I think later on in the books George
is going to break all this down for us
but that's just my opinion and it's
something I hope he does but it sounds
like they're saying Sam and brand find
this out together
so this must be at Winterfell don't you
think because we know that bran is head
in the Winterfell
and according to this plot leak it says
Sam heads back to Winterfell too so I'm
assuming if they found us out together
it has to be at Winterfell and where do
you think they could find something like
this out at Winterfell it'd have to be
down in the crypts I think something is
down there something very big something
important has to be down there and I
really can't wait to find out I hope
this part does come true because I
really want to see what's going on down
on those crypts so what do you guys
think he could have found out I heard
tell me in the comments
how you think this possibly worked out
but also in this episode it says that
John and Danny have sex on a boat so
tell me what you guys think about this
are you cool with John having sex with
his aunt I know the targaryen have done
this before that's not really what I'm
asking you guys but do you guys actually
want to see these two together in a
relationship
I'm sure the showrunners want this I
think social media would explode into a
frenzy if this happened they've been
building towards this for a very long
time these are the two biggest
characters and television right now so
it probably will happen but how much
longer do you actually expect Daenerys
to live this is the season 7 finale do
you guys actually see her living all the
way to the end of the show to the very
last episode of the entire series I
don't think she's going to live to see
the end do you guys I think one way or
another Danny's probably going to end up
dying but anyways the last part of this
episode says the wall was going to fall
at the end the night's king is going to
attack it with zombie Vasari on and
they're going to be able to knock it
down I think at this point in the show
this has to happen for the story to come
to this major climax the others are
going to have to get south in order to
pose the biggest threat that has been
talked about for most of this series and
when the night's king in his army get
through the wall I think [ __ ] is going
to get crazy
I think the intensity level on the show
is going to rise about a thousand
degrees there's going to be no more
magical barrier to protect the realm so
everyone's going to have to start
uniting and joining their forces you
guys know how the saying goes you're
going to have to stand together or
divided you're going to fall so they
better start getting a [ __ ] together but
I can't wait to see these battles and
ultimately probably the greatest war to
ever be displayed on a television screen
I think the very final battle is going
to be something epic
I hope they spend 50 million dollars on
that last battle I just want it to be
mind-blowing
but I guess if this is true then brands
mark is not going to be the thing that
allows the others to cross south of the
wall
so that's kind of interesting it kind of
felt like that was the whole point of
them doing that I didn't think they
showed brain get that mark just so they
can get into the cave unless it was just
for them to do the Hodor scene but I
felt like that mark was going to end up
playing out for something bigger I was
kind of hoping on I made a video about
that as well
I didn't think bran was going to be the
one to bring down the wall but it
definitely seemed like that was the
direction they were heading in but I
just kind of hoped it wasn't going to be
brands fault but uh do you guys really
think we're going to see a zombie dragon
personally I know I want to see one I
think it would be cool as hell could you
imagine seeing the night's king riding
on its back flying over top of
Winterfell with a million-man zombie
army marching below him I think that
would be absolutely terrifying so tell
me what you guys think of this alleged
finale would you guys like or dislike
about all this do you think it's true do
you think it's false give me your guys's
thoughts on everything and let's discuss
it in the comments like we usually do
thanks guys thanks for listening thanks
for the support thanks for sticking
around I appreciate everyone of you guys
for being here for watching it and
discussing this with me so thanks a lot
guys and I will see you in the next one
bye